قتل جندي اسرائيلي واصيب حارس لمستوطنه
بنيران الفلسطينيه استشهد
القاتل لاحقا عند او المنسق لاحقا عند
مدخل مستوطنه كادومين غرب مدينه نابلس في
الضفه الغربيه وقد تبنت حركه حماس العمليه
وهي الثالثه التي تنفذها المقاومه
الفلسطينيه منذ بدء اجتياح قوات الاحتلال
مخيم جنين الاثنين الماضي يتزامن هذا مع
قصف صاروخي ومدفعي متبادل على الحدود بين
اسرائيل وجنوب لبنان
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات
ما دلاله توالي عمليات المقاومه
الفلسطينيه في مواجهه التصعيد العسكري
وارتفاع وتيره تلك العمليات بعد اجتياح
الاحتلال جنين
كذلك ملء الانعكاسات المحتمله لتزايد
عمليات المقاومات الفلسطينيه على الصعيدين
الاسرائيلي والفلسطيني سيما بعد حديث
الاحتلال عن تكبده ثمنا باهظا في جنين
وما التاثيرات المحتمله للتصعيد
الاسرائيلي ورد المقاومه الفلسطينيه في
مواجهته على المنطقه خاصه بعد عوده اطلاق
النار للحدود اللبنانيه الاسرائيليه
[موسيقى]
يومان فقط بعد عمليه الاجتياح الواسعه
التي نفذها جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في
جنين وفي ثالث عمليه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه
منذ ذلك الاجتياح لقي جندي اسرائيلي حتفه
واصيب حارس مستوطنه بنيران مسلح فلسطيني
وذلك عند مدخل مستوطنه كادوميم غرب مدينه
نابلس الشماليه الضفه الغربيه منفذ
العمليه التي تبنتها كتائب القسام وقالت
ان اسمه احمد ياسين هلال غيضان وانه من
قريه قبيا غرب رام الله
استشهد بحسب مصادر اسرائيليه في اشتباك مع
قوه من جيش الاحتلال كانت تتعقبه وعقب
العمليه التي قالت كتائب القسام الجناح
العسكري لحركه حماس انها رد على عدوان
الاحتلال على جنين اقرر رئيس مجلس مستوطنه
كادومين بانهم يتعرضون لضغوط كبيره جراء
العمليات التي باتت تحدث باستمرار في
المستوطنات وعلى الطرق السريعه كذلك
عمليه كادوميه تزامنت مع قصف الجيش
الاسرائيلي منطقه كفر شوبا جنوبي لبنان
بخمسه عشره قذيفه مدفعيه ردا على اطلاق
صاروخين منها سقط حطام واحد منهما في
الجانب الاسرائيلي من الحدود وقد اثارت
الحادثه قلق قوات الامم المتحده العامله
في لبنان والتي دعت كافه الاطراف الى ضبط
النفس والامتناع عن القيام باعمال قد
تفاقم الاوضاع
[موسيقى]
ولمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا في بدايه هذه
الحلقه من القدس الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
الاسرائيلي نيسان
سيد نيسان اهلا بك
الان
عمليه ثالثه خلال ثلاثه ايام هل ما زالت
اسرائيل تصر على المقاربه الامنيه كنهج
للتعامل مع الفلسطينيين
اول
ا انا اريد ان اؤكد ان اسرائيل ليست ضد
الفلسطينيين في الغربيه وانما ضد ما تقوم
به بعض الفصائل الفلسطينيه مثل راينا في
مخيم جنين واقول ان هناك نمطين من
العمليات المسلحه النمط المنظم
كما راينا في مخيم جنين ونظم ونمط اخر
نمط فردي كما راينا اليوم في
العمليه التي قتل فيها في قدميم
السؤال الكبير الذي طرح هذا المساء وسيطرح
في مجلس الوزاري المصغر الذي ينعقد يوم
الاحد القادم لماذا اسرائيل تفصل بين
الضفه الغربيه وبين
قطاع غزه مع العلم ان صالح العروري الذي
يقطن في لبنان هو يريد تصعيد الاوضاع في
الضفه الغربيه وجعل وجعل جنين مثل ما هو
الوضع في قطاع غزه انت تعلمين تماما ان
ايضا حركه حماس تريد الفصل بين الضفه
الغربيه وبين قطاع غزه حركه حماس تريد
اشعال الاوضاع وتسعيد الاوضاع
في الضفه الغربيه بينما تريد مواصله
الهدوء والاستقرار في قطاع في قطاع غزه
ولماذا لان يوميا اكثر من 17 الف عامل
يدخلون الى اسرائيل
للبحث على لقبه خبز والمعاش وكل وكل عامل
الذي يدخل في اسرائيل ويعمل في اسرائيل
يقبض او يتقاضى معاش بثلاثه اضعاف او
اربعه اضعاف الماء يتقاضى في قطاع غزه
طبعا من هذا من هذا المعاش
تستفيد وضحت فكرتك
ولكن اليست الحقيقه ان ليست حماسيه من
يشعل فتيل المقاومه بقدر ما هي اسرائيل
بالطريقه التي تتعامل بها فقط دعني اذكر
لك ما ذكره ضابط اسرائيلي كبير مؤخرا قال
ان عدد الشبان الفلسطينيين بين 18 و 20
عام يقترب من 200 الف ويمكن ان ينفذ ايا
منهم عمليه في اي مكان في اسرائيل
هذا هو لب الموضوع
تفضل
القضيه كذلك
صحيح ان هناك مقاومه من قبل الفلسطينيين
صحيح ان
السلطه الفلسطينيه
رفعت يدها بكل ما يحدث في نابلس وفي كل ما
يحدث في جنين وهي احدثت الفراغ في هذين
هاتين
المدينتين عندما يكون هناك فراغ طبعا حركه
حماس تدخل في هذا الفراغ وراينا ما حدث
على سبيل المثال في في مخيم جنين السلطه
الفلسطينيه وابو مازن مع الاسف لم يعمل
شيئا لدخول الى هاتين المدينتين
بهدف اعاده السيطره للسلطه الفلسطينيه على
مجرات الامور
حركه حماس تهدد ليس اسرائيل وتهدد انما
ايضا السلطه الفلسطينيه كما راينا
الانقلاب الذي حدث على محمد دحلان في حينه
في قطاع غزه
وحركه حماس استولت على مجريات الامور في
قطاع غزه هكذا حركه حماس تريد رويدا رويدا
الاستيلاء من جنين على نابلس
يعني في الواقع يعني تظلت تدور في نفس
النقطه وانا اسالك عن موضوع ربما يختلف
بعض الشيء لانك انت تتحدث دائما وكان حماس
واي السلطه هي من يشعل الفطير المقاومه
بينما ما يقوله حتى الضابط الاسرائيلي كما
ذكرت لك قبل قليل يدل على ان الموضوع اذا
نعم اريد فقط ان اشير يعني يعني هل هناك
فعلا شرخ بين ما يقول القاده العسكريون
والامنيون من جهه وما يذهب اليه اليمين
المتطرف الذي ربما
يدفع بهذا المزيد من القمع ومن ثم تاتي
هذه الحلقه
اسمعي سيدتي المحترمه انا اقول لك بشكل
واضح ان ليس اي تاثير على الحكومه وعلى
رئيس الوزراء بكل ما يتعلق بالنفود من
جانب سموتريج او بجانب بنجفير دليل على
ذلك رئيس الوزراء لم يشارك في المشاورات
الامنيه التي على سبيل المثال اجريت قبل
اجتياح القوات الى جنين وهم كاي شخص اي
مواطن داخل اسرائيل علموا من وسائل
الاعلام ما حدث ولذلك ولذلك انا اقول انت
سالتني سؤال هناك هناك تبايع لا يوجد
تباين بين المستوى العسكري وبين المستوى
السياسي عندما المستوى العسكري على سبيل
المثال في عقب عمليات تقع وتؤدي الى
يعني اجبتني على السؤال هل هذا يعني ان
النهج مستمر بغض النظر عن عمليات المقاومه
في القدس والض فه وايضا الوضع على الحدود
مع لبنان والذي يتفجر وانفجر الان من جديد
وايضا الوضع الهش مع غزه كل هذا لن يدفع
اسرائيل لتعيد النظر في الطريقه التي
تتعامل فيها مع الفلسطينيين
بالعكس اولا اولا الطريق التي تتعامل بها
اسرائيل مع جانب الفلسطيني بشكل خاص مع
سلطه الفلسطينيه رغم اعلان ابو مازن عن
وقف التنسيق الامني بين اسرائيل وبين بين
الجيش الاسرائيلي وبين وبين سلطه
الفلسطينيه
التنسيق الامني ولمصلحه الطرفين
الاسرائيلي
والسلطه الفلسطينيه بكل ما يتعلق بكافه
الجبهات التي تعلمين تماما وربما اكثر مني
بما يحدث في بيروت هناك اجتماعات مكثفه
بين صالح العروري اسماعيل هنيه حسن نصر
الله وممثلين ايرانيين وهم يريدون اشعال
كافه الجبهات اذا كانت من قطاع غزه اذا
كانت من جنين اذا كانت من نابلس اذا كانت
اشعال لبنان وفي النهايه كما ذكرنا اكثر
من مره قد يكون هنا الاشعال بمعنى اخر
المسؤول اساسي عنه هو اسرائيل ولكن سنكتفي
بهذا القدر الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
الاسرائيلي من خلال القمع والطريقه التي
يتعامل مع هذا
الكافيه لتتحدث
اعطيتك الفرصه الكافيه للتحدث لنيسان
اشكرك والان ننتقل الى ضيفنا من رام الله
الدكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي الدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي معنا
الان وكذلك
ايهاب جبارين من الناصره اهلا وسهلا بكما
في موراء الخبر ابدا مع الدكتور مصطفى
البرغوثي هل نحن امام جيل فلسطيني جديد في
المقاومه يعتمد تكتيك جديد نهج جديد من
حيث العمل خارج التنظيمات
السياسيه والعسكريه
نحن بالتاكيد امام جيل جديد لا يقل همه
وعزما وعزيمه وتصميما عن الاجيال السابقه
في مقاومه الاحتلال ربما يلفت النظر في
اسم المقاومه الجديد ان اسمه احمد ياسين
يعني سمي على اسم الشهيد احمد ياسين
وهذا دليل على استمرار اجيال المقاومه
الواحد تلو الاخر لكن ما يجري ليس فقط ان
هناك جيل شجاع وباسل ولا يعرف وادرك بعمق
انه لا حل امامه سوى المقاومه في ظل القتل
والقمع الذي تمارسه اسرائيل وفي ظل
استيطان وارهاب المستوطنين وفي ظل اعلان
اسرائيل الواضح بضم وتهويد الضفه الغربيه
ليس امامه سوى المقاومه ولكن الذي نراه
اكبر من ذلك الذي نراه هو فعلا انتفاضه
شعبيه جديده بالمعنى الحرفي للكلمه يشارك
فيها هذا الجيل الجديد وكل الشعب
الفلسطيني كل بما يستطيع وكل بالطريقه
التي يستطيع ان يشارك فيها
ونرى حاضنه شعبيه وعوده للادراك العميق
بضروره تبني نهج المقاومه بعد ان فشلت كل
المناهج الاخرى وبعد بشكل خاص فشله نهج
التفاوض ونهج المراهنه على حلول الوسط مع
الحركه الصهيونيه لذلك الذي يجري يتحول
نوعي كبير وفعلا يعني اسرائيل فشلت فشلا
ذريعا ليس فقط في مخيم جنين رغم الدمار
الذي رايته اليوم وانا يعني ازور المخيم
ورغم الاجرام الذي مارسوه ضد العائلات
هناك لكنها فشلت فشلا ذريعا وبعد اعتدائها
على جنين تلقى الضربات في تل ابيب وتلقى
الضربات في لبنان وتلقت الان ضربه جديده
في عقر دار سموتريتش هذا العنصري المجرم
المتطرف الارهابي الذي يسمي حاله ارهابي
في كادومين المستعمره التي اقيمت على
اراضي كفر قدوم الفلسطينيه بالتالي الذي
نراه اليوم هو تحول عام
بين جيل الشباب الفلسطيني ولكن تحول عام
على نطاق الشعب الفلسطيني باسره نحو
العوده الى نهج المقاومه
الصحفي والخبير في شؤون الاسرائيليه ايهاب
الجبارين يعني وانت تتابع اذا كان هناك
النهج وتحول في المقاومه الفلسطينيه
تداعياته
اسرائيليا واضحه ايضا هناك عدد قتلى
ومصابين اكبر من الجانب الاسرائيلي هناك
تدهور اقتصادي هناك ايضا تراجع في التعاطف
الدولي حتى من اقرب حلفاء اسرائيل هل
نبالغ اذا قلنا ان ما يحدث الان لطمع
للعنجه هي الاسرائيليه
نعم مساء الخير بدون ادنى شك يعني هذه
الوصف الاداق يمكن لهذه الحاله بل اكثر من
ذلك انا عفوا بل اكثر بذلك انا بنظري يعني
يمكن ان نلخص ذلك بحاله الارباك التي كانت
اليوم تحديدا منذ صبيحه هذا اليوم يعني مع
الحاله الامنيه التي كانت في لبنان كان
هنالك الكثير من
يعني تناقل العناوين
بتناقضات معينه يعني بدات من هجمه صواريخ
وبعد ذلك العنوان التالي الذي كان في
الاعلام العبري حول لغم وبعد ذلك الصاروخ
مضاد
للصواريخ وما الى ذلك فبالتالي كان هنالك
واضح جدا ان الحاله الامنيه ربما حتى
المشهد السياسي يمكن القول يعيش في حاله
من البلبلات وهي نقطه يجب ان اوضحها
الحاله التي كانت في جنين في نهايه
المطافي كانت نوع من العلاقات العامه التي
اراد بنيامين نتنياهو وحكومته ان تديرها
ليس اتجاه الفلسطينيين تحديدا انما اتجاه
الشارع الاسرائيلي في ظل كل ما ذكرتيه في
ظل كل ما ذكرتيه من عدد قتلى لم يستوعبه
اي من الحكومات السابقه بل كان يعني يعاير
بحكومه بنت ولا بيد على عدد القتل الذي
كان والان هو تفوق عليه ربما بالضعف في ظل
كل هذه الحاله هو حاول ان يصور نفسه بانه
سوف يستطيع ان يعيد هذه الرهبه والعنجهيه
وقوه الردع الاسرائيليه لكنه في غضون
الاثنين ساعه منذ ان بدا حمله العلاقات
العامه العسكريه الامنيه ان صح القول هو
تلقى على الاقل خمس ضربات موجعه وهنالك
ملاحظه جدا يعني تم تغيبها عن الاعلام
تقليص افوها وشانها بمفهوم كهذا او كاخر
وهذا غيره يعني لا ينطوف
الاسرائيليه المعهوده
فبالتالي واضح جدا ان هذا ما يحاول
نقطه ثالثه يجب ان نتطرق اليها في نهايه
المطاف ان كل ما يقوم به الان بن يمين
نتنياهو هي في ظل بالذات في ظل هذه
الحكومه حكومه اليمين المتطرفه الاكثر
يمينيه ومتشدده ان شئنا كذلك هي في ظل عدم
وجود مشروع سياسي واضح
لليمين المتطرف هذا تحديدا اليمين
الاستيطاني يعني المشروع السياسي الوحيد
الموجود لديه للمناوره السياسيه في داخل
الحلبه الاسرائيليه هو فقط الاستيطان
وبالتالي الاحتلال يعني ممكن ان نقول
بكلمات اخرى هو يعتاش من هذه الحاله ولكن
امنيا وعسكريا هنالك حاله من الارباك لان
حتى يعني اسرائيل كانت ممكن ان تطور
الحاله الامنيه كان ممكن ان تطور
استراتيجيات لتعامل مع مراحل ذات عناوين
مع الانتفاضه الاولى مع الانتفاضه الثانيه
مع ما سمته انذاك انتفاضه السكاكين كان
يمكنها ان تتعامل وفق استراتيجيات لكل
مرحله حتى في داخل في جنوب لبنان
واحتلالها للبنان على صعيد ذكر لبنان ولكن
في هذه المرحله يوجد حاله من الفوضى وهي
تخاف ان تعطيها عنوان لهذه المرحله لسبب
واحد ووحيد لانها تعلم جيدا ان كان هنالك
وحده في الصف الفلسطيني وحده في جبهات
الفلسطينيه سوف ينتج عن ذلك حاله سياسيه
شبه موحده في الصف الفلسطيني وهذا ما لا
يريده بين يمين نتنياهو ابدا طيب دكتور
مصطفى البرغوثي تكلمنا عن جنوب لبنان وهي
الان جبهه ايضا
يعني دخلت على الصف في وقت
ربما يعتبر البعض انه قد يكون اكثر تاثيرا
لو انه تزامن مع عمليه جنين هل توافق
لا لا اطلاقا انا اعتقد انه
الذي جرى يعني علينا ان نتذكر عمليه جنين
انتهت قبل يوم يعني وبالتالي فعليا واول
رد فعل مقاوم جرى اثناء عمليه جنين في تل
ابيب وبالتالي هناك تزامن واضح بين
المقاومه الفلسطينيه التي ردت على العدوان
على جنين
واهم في الامر انه الاعتداء يعني اسرائيل
كانت تحاول ان تصور ان المقاومه محصوره في
جنين او في نابلس اليوم تلقت ردود في جنين
وتلقت درود في طولكرم وتلقت ردود من
الخليل ومن رام الله الان وبالتالي هذه
المحاوله لعزل منطقه بعينها وتصويرها
بانها هي مركز المقاومه الوحيد طبعا فشلت
فشلا ذريعا انا برايي ان اسرائيل ونتنياهو
وحكومته الفاشيه يكررون بالفعل ما قالوا
اينشتاين وهو الجنون بعينه بانهم يعيدون
تكرار نفس عمليات القمع والقتل ويتوقعون
نتائج مختلفه والنتائج هي ذاتها تصاعد
المقاومه الفلسطينيه اريد ان اركز ايضا
على ان اسرائيل واستراتيجيهها وانتم سمعتم
ذلك في حديث الاعلاميين الاسرائيليين
يحاول ان يفصلوا بين الشعب والمقاومه
والنتيجه احتضان شعبي رائع وواسع وغير
مسبوق للمقاومه يحاول ان يفصلوا بين الضفه
وغزه وهناك تكامل رائع بين الضفه وغزه
يحاولوا ان يكرسوا الانقسام بين فتح وحماس
ويحاول ان يحرض السلطه على شعبها وذلك
ايضا يفشل لانه الذي نراه الان توجه نحو
توحيد الصف الوطني ونحو تشكيل قياده وطنيه
فلسطينيه موحده على استراتيجيه وطنيه
كفاحيه مقاومه وبالتالي ما يحاول نتنياهو
ان يحققه هو وحلفائه الفاشين من امثال
سموتريج وبنجف يرتد عليهم بعكس تماما ما
حاولوا ان يصلوا اليه الان الحاله
الفلسطينيه واضحه
الفلسطيني واضح لم يعد احد يراهن على ما
فشل سابقا الجميع الان مقتنعون انه لا حل
سوى تغيير ميزان القوه عبر المقاومه
والكفاح وعبر استنهاض اوسع قدر ممكن من
على الصعيد الشعبي عالميا لعزل اسرائيل
وفضحها وتعريتها وفرض العقوبات والمقاطعه
عليها هذا هذا هو النهج الذي يتعمق الان
في فلسطين
وتتعمق معه مشاعر التضامن والتكافل مع
المقاومه الفلسطينيه بكل اشكالها ومشاعر
الاحترام الكبير لكل من يضحي من اجل وطنه
ويضحي من اجل شعبه سواء كان شهيدا او
جريحا او مناضلا باشكال اخرى حاله التضامن
والتكافل الشعبي غير مسبوقه وهي تعيدنا
بالفعل الى روح الانتفاضه الشعبيه الاولى
روح الاعتماد على النفس روح تنظيم النفس
تحدي الاحتلال وسط كل هذا دكتور مصطفى
وانتقل لايهاب جبارين
وسط كل هذا ياتي
بنيامين نتنياهو بكل جراه ويقول اريد ان
ازيل الدوله الفلسطينيه يتحدث عن اجتيثات
الدوله الفلسطينيه هل كان
بنيامينه اليهود يجرا ان يفعل ذلك دون
الدعم السياسي الامريكي الذي يتلقاه ومن
ثم الحصول على دعم دولي في القضيه الى اي
حد هو فعلا واقعي في هذه المرحله
نعم يجب ان نتذكر ان يمينه تحديدا في عام
97 دخل الى الحكومه للمره الاولى 96
تحديدا لكن بدا يناور افعالهم في 97 حتى
عام 99 اداره حكومه اسرائيليه كانت تتسم
تلك المرحله بالاكثر هدوءا ان صح القول في
يعني في تلك المرحله
واخذ اوسلو وربما اضاف عليها بعض الشيء
ربما تم تعديل بعض الامور ولكنه لم يلغيها
في عام 2009 وبسبب ذلك هو خسر الانتخابات
في عام 2009 اتى بين يمين نتنياهو مع نهج
مغاير كليا نهج يميني متطرف نوعا ما اكثر
تطرفا مما كان هو كان يمينيا بدون اي
مشاكل لكنه اكثر تطرفا مما كان
ومنذ تلك المرحله يعني على اربعه عشر عاما
بدا باخذ خطوات ربما حتى طمست معالم ما
قام به الريال في اخر سنوات اريال شاون
حاول يعني ان بدا بخطه الانفصال
ازال اربع مستوطنات من شمال الضفه راينا
نتاج ذلك فقط في الايام الاخيره كيف
اعادها بنيامين اليوم ففي غضون 15 عام 14
عام
يعني اخذ خطوات متسارعه كليا في طمس معالم
الدوله الفلسطينيه العتيده ان صح القول
بهذه المفاهيمه الان في هذه المرحله بنينه
انه يستغل عده ظروف اهمها اهم كاس هذه
الظروف هو ضعف الاداره الامريكيه الحاليه
الديمقراطيه الحاليه من جهه ومن جهه ثانيه
كذلك هو يعمل على ابتزازها بكثير من
المعايير يعني ضعفها اقليميا
ابتزازها بكل ما يخص الاتفاق النووي
الايراني اذا اردتم ان تشتروا صمتي ان هنا
ادير
حكومه من اليمين المتطرف وبالتالي علي
الكثير من الضغوطات ولاحظ هنالك نقطه مهمه
جدا يجب ان ندركها
يستعمل
كفزاعه
ولا يقل التطرفا عنهما حتى رؤياهم يحملون
ذات الرؤيه يعني رؤيه الدوله الواحده من
البحر الى النهر
ربما لديهم طموحات حتى اكثر ان صح القبل
وبالتالي ولكن نقطه مهم جدا الاختلاف هو
فقط في التكتيك والاستراتيجيات ليس الا
شكرا جزيلا لك الصحفي والخبير في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه ايهاب جبارين من الناصره
وشكرا للدكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين
العام للمبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا على متابعه هذه الحلقه
من برنامج ما وراء الخبر
[موسيقى]